the president of the united states
said yesterday in north carolina that
voters
should try to vote twice he actually
said
you should go out there in north
carolina
mail in a vote and then on election day
go
and try to vote now donald trump is
suggesting this as a sort of
test of our election system donald trump
has tried to make
the public believe that our voting
systems
are so terrible so antiquated so bogus
that people could easily get away with
mailing in a ballot
and then going and voting and then your
vote is counted twice
now if the systems are working correctly
i've explained this to you
if you have sent in a ballot and then
you go in to vote in person it will show
up
you've already voted we've already
received your ballot via
absentee if the opposite happens
imagine for a moment that you send in a
ballot via mail but it hasn't been
received on election day
you go in and vote on election day and
you're allowed to
and then the next day your mail-in
ballot is received
that ballot would not be counted because
you've already been checked off as
having voted now
of course in a country of 331 million
anything can happen and anecdotally
there are probably
some cases of double votes getting by
people
much like there are cases of voting
machines going wrong
and you press one person and it
accidentally you know or
because of manipulation as some would
say casts a ballot
for the other guy or gal it's a country
of 331 million people
but the idea that that's widespread and
the idea that that's a good way to win
an election
is absolutely laughable well it's also a
felony in north carolina
and here is donald trump encouraging
voters
to commit a crime take a look at this
well i they'll go out and they'll vote
and they're gonna have to go and check
their vote by going to the poll and
voting that way because
if it tabulates then they won't be able
to do that
so let them send it in and let them go
vote
and if their system's as good as they
say it is then obviously they won't be
able to vote
if it isn't tabulated they'll be able to
vote so that's the way it is
but send in your ballots send them in
strong whether it's solicited or
unsolicited the absentees are fine we
have to work to get them you know it
means something
and you send them in but you go to vote
and if they haven't counted it you can
vote
so that's the way i view it so this is a
crime
this is a crime the law actually says
intentionally double voting is a crime
put aside the fact
that it really would not work unless
something goes wrong
as i as i mentioned earlier if you mail
it in
you wouldn't be allowed to get an
in-person ballot if you vote in person
and then a mail-in ballot comes in the
mail-in ballot would be considered
spoiled
but this is a felony in north carolina
and in an interview last year kim wyman
who's the secretary of state in
washington state where
they've been doing vote by mail for
years she said
that the these double voting scenarios
are extremely rare she said quote we can
usually run a list of people who have
appeared to vote more than once
out of 3.5 million ballots in 2018 it
appears 100 people may have voted more
than once counties are checking
100 people out of 3.5 million ballots
and of course of those hundred many of
them were were caught that this is the
number of people who tried to vote
more than once and kim wyman added is it
perfect
no is there rampant fraud no
do people sometimes make mistakes yes
now
here's the kicker donald trump is not
only suggesting that
voters commit a crime because it is a
crime to willfully go
and and try to vote twice donald trump
committed a crime
donald trump was in north carolina where
when he said this
and in north carolina it is a felony for
quote any person with intent to commit
a fraud to register or vote at more than
one precinct or more than one time
or to induce another to do so
so voting more than once is against the
law
and is a felony in north carolina and
suggesting to other people that they do
it
is also a crime in north carolina
and voting more than once is also
illegal under federal law
and all of this is really focused around
doing one thing
cast doubt on election results in
advance
so that if it's close if it's not close
quite frankly no matter what the results
are
donald trump will be able to say i've
been telling you all along
i've been telling you all along it's
rigged rigged rigged
and that's exactly what he's doing trump
is committing crimes in front of cameras
in order to do it
and who knows how many of his supporters
are going to be induced to commit a
crime
based on what donald trump said
yesterday we have to end this
we we have to get this malignancy
out of the white house and he's going to
do anything he can think of
announcing the vaccine uh suggesting
people test the system
dissuading people from voting post
office foreign meddling
it's all in play and we have to
overwhelm the vote in order to prevent
it
you know that that's the way to do it at
this point eight weeks out
i know that it's the way to do it as
well i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
sussman and han sussman and han has
everything you need
when it comes to face masks and other
protective gear for covid19
and they're giving my audience 20 off
sussman and han is the company that i
personally have been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor
i have tried tons of different masks
this year
and i still have not found a mask that's
more comfortable or easier to breathe in
than the washable cotton masks that they
sell it's made of a silky lightweight
cotton that feels great on your skin
it has convenient adjustable straps it
features a disposable five-layer
particle filter made of activated carbon
they also have disposable cloth masks
which are really comfortable as well as
other gear
like face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers
and all of their prices are very
reasonable i also love sussman and han
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions they're
a great company
you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is underneath this video
and you can save
twenty percent off of everything in
their store
when you use the coupon code david